Just like we learned in lesson three, that there are
different alleles for the ABO gene, there are also different alleles
for the lactase gene, but the difference is that the ABO
alleles, we're in the coding region. You can see here allele
1 and allele 2. There the star marks a change
here in the coding region. But in the lactase gene example,
the difference between allele 1 and allele 2 doesn't have anything
to do with coding region. It has everything to do with
the non-coding region. Now remember, you still get
two copies of every gene, including the lactase
gene. That counts the coding and the non-coding
regions. Which combination of alleles would result in lactose
intolerance? There are three options. Two cytosines, a
cytosine and a thiamine, or two thiamines. Remember
the order of the alleles doesn't matter, whether
it's CT or TC, so we still just have
three options total. Go ahead and select
any and all options that you think apply.